This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. The English poet William Wordsworth once wrote that the world is too much with us. He penned those words in 1807, a time of growing industrialization in his country. William Wordsworth felt that people were becoming detached from nature and were too absorbed in, as he put it, getting and spending. His critique still rings true. We are surrounded today by more people connected to more devices and travel more often and widely.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。英国诗人威廉·华兹华斯曾写道，世界对我们来说过于繁嚣。他在1807年写下这些字句时，他的国家正经历日益加剧的工业化。威廉·华兹华斯感到人们正在脱离自然，并正如他所说的那样，过度沉溺于获取和消费。他的批判至今仍然振聋发聩。如今我们周围有更多的人连接着更多的设备，并且旅行得更频繁、更广泛。
From time to time, of course, we stop. We take a hike in the mountains or spend an afternoon reading a book. We are transformed by a lovely piece of music or sit by a window listening to the rain. These moments rejuvenate us. We tell ourselves, I should do this more often. And then we don't. That's because the world constantly tells us
当然，我们偶尔也会停下脚步。我们在山里徒步，或者花一个下午读本书。我们被一首优美的音乐所改变，或者坐在窗前聆听雨声。这些时刻让我们焕发活力。我们告诉自己，我应该多做这种事。然后我们却没有。那是因为这个世界不断地告诉我们
that William Wordsworth was wrong, that getting and spending is the good life We should reach for that next ring work that third job Go to that boisterous party after a long day at work Work hard play hard. You only live once right? Movies and TV shows depict people who sit on the sidelines, who consciously step away from the crowds, as standoffish and strange. That figure sitting by a rain-spattered window?
威廉·华兹华斯是错的，获取和消费才是美好的生活，我们应该争取下一个更高的目标、打第三份工、在漫长的工作日后去参加那个喧闹的派对。努力工作，尽情玩乐。人生只有一次，对吧？电影和电视节目把那些作壁上观、有意识地远离人群的人描绘成冷漠而怪异的人。那个坐在被雨水打湿的窗前的人呢？
She looks lonely. Today on the show, we explore the signs of what we lose when we constantly engage in getting and spending. And we'll examine the effects on our minds of a quieter, more reflective interior life. How to make friends with yourself again, this week on Hidden Brain. Researchers are people, and like all of us, they make assumptions. Sometimes those assumptions are right, but often they're wrong. That's where the data come in. If you track things carefully, you can start to see where your assumptions go wrong.
她看起来很孤独。今天的节目中，当我们不断参与获取和消费时，我们将探讨这些行为所带来的种种失落的迹象。我们将审视一个更安静、更内省的内。心生活对我们心灵的影响。本周在Hidden Brain，教你如何重新与自己做朋友。研究人员也是人，和我们所有人一样，他们也有假设。有时这些假设是对的，但往往是错的。这就是数据发挥作用的地方。如果你仔细追踪事物，你就能开始看出你的假设在哪些地方出了错。
In early 2020, psychologist Neda Weinstein at the University of Reading in Britain made an assumption. She wanted to study the psychological impacts of the COVID pandemic as it swept across the globe. Her assumption was that social distancing would be an overwhelmingly negative experience for many people. We were worried and we anticipated that we'd see increases in loneliness,
在2020年初，英国雷丁大学的心理学家内达·温斯坦提出了一个假设。随着COVID大流行席卷全球，她想研究这场大流行的心理影响。她的假设是，对于许多人来说，社交距离将是一次压倒性的消极体验。我们感到担忧，并且我们预计会看到孤独感的增加，
that we'd see increases in anxiety and depression. And so our first project kind of jumping into this was to map people's anxiety, loneliness, depression across months of lockdown and try to predict who is sort of resilient to those kinds of costs of the lockdown experience. those kinds of costs of the lockdown experience. Now roughly one in three adults in the in in Britain live on their own live live by themselves. I'm assuming you you might have worried that these people might be especially hard hit they were already in some ways socially
我们预计会看到焦虑和抑郁的增加。因此，我们着手开展的第一个项目就是绘制人们在几个月的封锁期间的焦虑、孤独、抑郁情况，并试图预测谁对封锁体验带来的这类代价具有某种程度的韧性。封锁体验带来的这类代价。现在，英国大约有三分之一的成年人自己居住、独自生活。我假设你可能曾担心这些人可能会遭受沉重打击，他们在某些方面本来就已经处于社会
isolated or you worried that they were suffering from loneliness and now you have this enforced loneliness where some of the social contact that they might have had by going out and making friends with the baker, that that would have fallen by the wayside as well. Absolutely. So, for those of us who lived with somebody else, we had different risks. So parents struggle because they were in close quarters
隔离状态，或者你担心他们正遭受孤独的折磨，现在又有了这种强制的孤独，他们原本可以通过外出和面包师交朋友而获得的一些社交接触，也将不复存在了。绝对是这样。所以，对于我们这些与其他人同住的人来说，我们面临着不同的风险。因此父母们会挣扎，因为他们整天都与孩子近距离相处，平衡工作和育儿可能会很困难。伴侣们面临着挑战，你可能会想，我真的很喜欢和我住在一起的人。但对于独居的成年人来说，这真的是关于找不到任何人来接触。如果你被困在家里
with their children all day long and balancing work and childcare might be difficult. Partners were challenged, you think, to I really like the person that I live with. But living alone adults, it was really about having nobody to access. And if you're stuck in the house
而周围没有其他人，那就意味着长时间的独处。所以在2020年大流行的头一年晚些时候，你和你的同事发表了这项研究的第一轮发现。内达，你们报道了什么？所以，我们寻找的事情之一就是寻找某种证据
and there's nobody else there, it means long periods of solitude. So later in that first pandemic year of 2020, you and your colleagues published your first round of findings from the research project. What did you report, Neda? So one of the things we were looking for is we were looking for kind of evidence
证明我们独处的动机可以保护我们免受那种负面影响，你知道的，比如来自孤独、抑郁或焦虑的影响。我们当时想，当你思考人们处于封锁状态的原因时，对某些人来说，他们真的理解封锁的重要性。因此，我们在寻找这样的人：他们觉得，是的，留在家中并且独处真的非常重要，因为我理解这对于公共健康以及我自己的健康的重要性。我认为这是一件有价值的事情。所以我们在寻找那种
that the motivation that we have for being alone can protect us from those kind of negative effects, you know, from loneliness or depression or anxiety. And we thought when you think about the reasons people were in lockdown, for some people they really understood the importance of lockdown. So we were looking for people who felt like, yeah, it's really important that I stay at home and I'm alone because I understand the importance for kind of public health, for my own health. I think it's a valuable thing to do. So we were looking for those sort of markers
积极的独处动机的标志。我们还在寻找那些对独处感到非常大压力且别无选择的人。你知道，是不是有些人只是觉得我这么做完全是因为我别无选择？而实际上这感觉非常受控制，那些只是觉得我这么做完全是因为我别无选择的人，实际上感觉这非常受控制
of kind of positive motivation for solitude. And we were also looking for people who felt just really pressured and choiceless and being alone. You know, were there some people who just felt like I'm only doing this because I have no choice at all? And actually it feels very kind of controlled people who just felt like I'm only doing this because I have no choice at all and actually it feels very kind of controlled and coercive of the government to put me in this position. And what we expect is that those people who felt like they were being pressured or coerced, that
并且政府把我们置于这种境地具有强迫性。而我们的预期是，那些感到自己被施压或被迫的人，
they would have more loneliness across time, more anxiety, and have more symptoms of depression. time, more anxiety, and have more symptoms of depression. And we didn't find strong evidence of those effects. We found very weak evidence. And the reason was actually what surprised us the most. The reason is that people didn't really increase in anxiety, depression, and loneliness the way that we had expected them to. anxiety, depression and loneliness the way that we had expected them to. Neta's starting point for the study was wrong. Her assumptions about how lockdowns would damage people's well-being were off base. What we saw is that across those early months, there wasn't really a lot of evidence that there was something that needed protecting.
随着时间的推移会有更多的孤独感、更多的焦虑，并且会有更多的抑郁症状。时间推移，会有更多的焦虑，并表现出更多的抑郁症状。我们没有发现这些效应的强有力证据。我们发现的证据非常微弱。而原因实际上是我们最意想不到的。原因在于，人们并没有像我们预期那样，焦虑、抑郁和孤独感显著增加。焦虑、抑郁和孤独感并没有像我们预期那样增加。内达这项研究的出发点是错误的。她关于封锁将如何损害人们福祉的假设偏离了方向。我们看到的是，在头几个月里，并没有太多证据表明有什么东西需要保护。
People's mental health problems just didn't increase. And the kind of really surprising thing when I look back and you kind of look back and you have the benefit of hindsight and the wisdom of age here a few years later is I look back at that study and I think, well, we didn't actually measure anything positive at all. We only measured negative mental health indicators like depression and anxiety. We didn't measure the potential benefits people could have had being home alone during lockdowns. And we never asked the question, could it be that some people were doing more than okay? Some people were really, you know, finding some benefits in it. So following the release of those results, Neda, you published another study the following year. What were you looking to find in this study and what did you find? You know, I think we learned something. I learned something in that
人们的心理健康问题根本没有增加。而当我回首过去，你回顾过去，并且在几年后拥有了事后诸葛亮的视角和成熟的智慧时，真正令人惊讶的事情是，我回想起那项研究时心想，嗯，我们实际上根本没有测量任何积极的东西。我们只测量了诸如抑郁和焦虑等消极的心理健康指标。我们没有测量人们在封锁期间独自在家时可能获得的潜在好处。而且我们从没有提出过这样的问题：有没有可能某些人的状况不仅仅是“还好”？有些人真的，你知道的，在其中找到了一些好处。所以在这些结果公布之后，内达，你在第二年又发表了另一项研究。在这项研究中，你希望发现什么？你又发现了什么？你知道的，我认为我们学到了东西。我在那项
initial study that was focused on anxiety, depression, loneliness, and none of the potential benefits of solitude. And so I ran a study that was meant to start to understand solitude across the lifespan. So we were looking at adolescents from age 13 to age 16, and we were comparing them to adults and older adults. adolescents from age 13 to age 16. And we were comparing them to adults and older adults. One of the things that we saw, and it's not the only time that we've seen this result,
最初的研究中学到了一些东西，那项研究专注于焦虑、抑郁、孤独，而完全没有关注独处的任何潜在好处。因此我进行了一项研究，旨在开始了解整个生命周期的独处。所以我们研究了13岁到16岁的青少年，并将他们与成年人和老年人进行比较。13岁至16岁的青少年。我们将他们与成年人和老年人进行了比较。我们看到的情况之一，而且这并不是我们第一次看到这个结果，
is that older adults felt most peaceful and least lonely in their solitude time. And they were followed by adolescents. So actually it was middle-aged adults who struggled the most with solitude. But we also asked them to sort of openly reflect on what the costs and benefits of solitude were for them and what they potentially learned about themselves or about relationships from their time in solitude. And when you looked at those stories of solitude and what people really remembered, they often
是老年人在他们的独处时间里感到最平静，最不孤独。其次是青少年。所以实际上是中年成年人与独处斗争得最厉害。但我们也要求他们公开反思独处对他们来说的成本和收益是什么，以及他们可能从独处时间里了解到了关于自己或人际关系的什么。当你审视那些关于独处的故事以及人们真正记住的事情时，他们经常
talked a lot about solitude being a time when they could rely on themselves, solitude being a time when they were sort of free and independent, when they could be with themselves. There was one really lovely quote from one of our participants who wrote, I learned to listen to my own desires, needs, and wishes. In many countries around the world, we incline toward negative views about being by ourselves, regarding it as draining or depressing, a state to be avoided whenever possible. In the minds of many people, being alone equals being lonely. But what if that equation is wrong? When we come back, the science of solitude. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
谈论很多关于独处是他们可以依靠自己的时间，独处是他们某种程度上自由和独立、可以与自己相处的时间。我们的一位参与者说了一句非常美妙的话，他写道：“我学会了倾听我自己的渴望、需求和愿望。”在世界上的许多国家，我们倾向于对独处持有负面的看法，认为它消耗精力或令人沮丧，是一件只要有可能就应该避免的事情。在许多人的心中，独处等于孤独。但是如果这个等式是错的呢？当我们回来时，将探讨独处的科学。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。
I'm Shankar Vedant. Most of us have had experiences where we are on the outside looking in. We see other people having fun, enjoying each other's company. We feel our own isolation keenly. Psychologist Neda Weinstein got to experience this painfully when she was a small child. She grew up in Israel and had felt ensconced within a community. One year, when she was nine, her parents proposed a vacation to Disneyland.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们大多数人都曾有过身处局外向里看的经历。我们看到其他人玩得很开心，享受彼此的陪伴。我们深刻地感受到了自身的孤立。心理学家内达·温斯坦（Neda Weinstein）在她还是个小孩子时就痛苦地体验过这一点。她在以色列长大，曾觉得自己安稳地融入了一个社区。在她九岁那年的一年，她的父母提议去迪士尼乐园度假。
The amusement park was fun, but the trip wasn't really about a vacation. The family was actually moving to the United States. We stayed in the LA and then San Diego area for the rest of my childhood. And so for me, that was a defining moment in kind of my young life. I went from having neighborhood friends and really a pretty independent lifestyle. We lived in a small town. I could go wherever I wanted.
游乐园很有趣，但这次旅行其实并不是为了度假。这家人实际上是要搬去美国。我们在洛杉矶和圣地亚哥地区度过了我童年的其余时光。所以对我来说，那是我年轻生命中具有决定性意义的一个时刻。我从拥有邻里朋友和相当独立的生活方式转变为——我们住在一个小镇里。我可以去任何我想去的地方，
I can meet with whoever I wanted to moving to this kind of big, strange city where people spoke a language that I didn't speak and the kids were really quite different. Hmm. So I'm wondering at the point at which this visit that you thought was primarily to Disneyland turned into a permanent move at what point did you realize oh my god we've actually moved from from Israel to this other country and what did that what did that feel like?
我可以见任何我想见的人——搬到一个这样的大型陌生城市，这里的人们说着一种我不会说的语言，而且孩子们真的相当不同。嗯。所以我想知道，在你以为这次访问主要是去迪士尼乐园，却变成了一次永久搬迁的那个时间点上，你在哪个时刻意识到，哦天哪，我们其实已经从以色列搬到了这个别的国家，那是什么感觉，那是一种什么样的感受？
You know, it really hit home. I don't remember the exact moment when it sort of went from being a vacation to being the rest of my life. But it sort of hit home when I started school, and I started kind of public school in San Diego, and I didn't speak any English. In fact, I a little bit thought that everybody spoke in Hebrew inside their heads and then translated to whatever language they spoke out loud. So there was a lot of learning for me to do about the world clearly.
你知道的，这真的深深触动了我。我不记得那个具体的时间点了，它从一次度假变成了我余下的生活。但当我开始上学时，这种感觉真正冲击了我，我开始在圣地亚哥上公立学校，而我不会说任何英语。事实上，我有点认为每个人在脑海里都用希伯来语思考，然后翻译成他们大声说出的任何语言。很显然，我对这个世界的认知还有很多需要学习的地方。
And we moved in, things were really very different in the US, not just the language barrier with friends, but the culture's very different. Kids behave very differently in San Diego than they do in Israel, and the kinds of activities that they do to connect. So my friends and I in Israel, we used to just kind of spend time together, hang out, sort of, you know,
当我们搬过去时，美国的情况真的很不一样，不仅仅是与朋友之间的语言障碍，文化也非常不同。圣地亚哥的孩子们的行为方式与以色列的孩子们非常不同，他们用来建立联系的活动也很不一样。所以我和以色列的朋友们过去常常只是花时间在一起，闲逛，某种程度上，你知道的，
loiter around our little village. And in the U.S., kids played a lot of ball sports and things that I hadn't been exposed to before. During the school day, recess became a time when Neda realized how lonely she was. I remember that pretty vividly even so many years later, that kind of sense of not quite fitting in or not really knowing how to behave, what the scripts are that I meant to follow. Probably didn't think about it in quite that way. And probably in some ways that was my first real sense of solitude in a kind of big way that I felt really alone
在我们的村子里闲晃。而在美国，孩子们玩很多球类运动以及我以前没有接触过的东西。在学校期间，课间休息成了内达意识到自己有多孤独的一段时间。即使过了这么多年，我依然相当生动地记得那种感觉：那种不太合群的感觉，或者不太知道该如何行为、不知道自己应该遵循什么样的剧本的感觉。可能当时并没有以那种方式去思考。并且在某些方面，那可能是我在很大程度上第一次真正感受到独处，我感到非常孤独，
because there wasn't the opportunity to connect and there wasn't the language to connect either. I'm wondering if your teachers and parents sort of noticed that you were feeling isolated, feeling lonely. Did they do things to try and make you feel more connected? You know, at the time I think there was less awareness of maybe mental health or social connection. And I'm not really sure,
因为没有建立联系的机会，也没有建立联系的语言。我想知道你的老师和父母是否注意到你感到被孤立、感到孤独。他们有没有做什么事情来试图让你感觉联系更紧密？你知道的，在当时，我认为大家对心理健康或社会联系的意识可能较少。我其实不太确定，
because again, I have the kind of a child's memory in this, but I do remember that I don't think anybody really picked up on it. So my parents were quite busy with a big transition and a big move and new careers. And so they were pretty occupied and the teachers in the school that I went to really were responsible for a lot of children.
因为同样地，我对这件事保留着一种儿童时期的记忆，但我确实记得，我认为没有人真正注意到这一点。所以我的父母当时忙于一次巨大的过渡、一次重大的搬迁以及新的职业生涯。因此他们相当忙碌，而且我去的学校里的老师真的要负责很多孩子。
It was very easy to fall through the cracks. And I don't remember them ever really picking up on this kind of, you know, little isolated girl that was there, who maybe was more likely to go off and play on her own. Netta's story might remind you of times when you were lonely yourself. And you've probably read news reports about the growing epidemic of loneliness in the United States and other countries. But as Neda became a researcher, she slowly became fascinated by the benefits of the time we spend alone. I asked her if that meant she didn't think loneliness was a serious problem.
非常容易被忽视。我不记得他们真正注意到这个孤立的小女孩，她可能更容易独自一人走开玩耍。内达的故事可能会让你想起你自己感到孤独的时刻。你可能也读过关于美国和其他国家孤独流行日益严峻的新闻报道。但随着内达成为一名研究人员，她慢慢地对我们独自度过的时间所带来的益处着迷了。我问她，这是否意味着她不认为孤独是一个严重的问题。
Loneliness is absolutely a problem in many countries, and I'm definitely not going to go up and say, you know, we shouldn't be concerned about loneliness or we shouldn't invest in learning more about how to help reduce loneliness in the world. I think there's a lot of research that shows that there are mental health and physical health costs of loneliness. So, if you say that loneliness is a problem and it actually does have these serious problems for both our mental health and physical health, what is the distinction you're drawing between loneliness and solitude, which you say has many benefits? So I think this distinction is really important.
孤独绝对是许多国家的一个问题，我绝对不会站出来说，你知道的，我们不应该关注孤独，或者我们不应该投资去更多地了解如何帮助减少世界上的孤独。我认为有很多研究表明，孤独会带来心理健康和身体健康方面的代价。因此，如果你说孤独是一个问题，并且它确实给我们的心理健康和身体健康带来了这些严重问题，那么你对孤独（loneliness）和独处（solitude）的区分是什么？你曾说过独处有很多好处。所以我觉得这种区分非常重要。
And you know, when we think about loneliness and solitude, we actually tend to conflate them a little bit in our minds. And we're a little bit wired to do so. And there are probably a number of reasons that we're wired to do so. And the first is that we're kind of social animals. A lot of what we learn comes from other people, of course. And so solitude has always been an uneasy thing for us
你知道的，当我们想到孤独和独处时，我们实际上倾向于在头脑中将它们稍微混为一谈。而且我们的大脑在某种程度上就是这样被连线的。这样连线可能有很多原因。首先，我们某种程度上是社会性动物。我们学到的很多东西当然都来自于其他人。因此，作为社会性动物，
as social animals. And even the way that we talk about solitude, so our language for solitude is quite conflated with loneliness. Even up until recently when we said the word solitude, we still referred to it as a state of loneliness. When I am in solitude, it actually means I feel deeply lonely or isolated. And when we look at languages around the world now, many
独处对我们来说一直是一件令人不安的事。甚至连我们谈论独处的方式也是如此——我们用来表达独处的语言与孤独高度混淆。直到最近，当我们说出“独处”（solitude）这个词时，我们仍然把它称为一种孤独的状态。当我处于独处时，它实际上意味着我感到深深的孤独或被孤立。当我们审视现在世界各地的语言时，许多
of those languages don't have a separate word for solitude to the one that means loneliness. So as a solitude researcher, it's actually quite difficult to do solitude work because we don't have a way of communicating to our participants about what solitude is that is not loneliness as well. And of course when you call someone a loner in society that is not a compliment. Exactly and a loner is not somebody who feels lonely, a loner is somebody who spends time alone. And so we really think about them in the same space. And because we tend to do so, and we have done so kind of historically, and as part of our sort of culture and our traditions, and all around the world, it continues to be,
语言中并没有一个单独的词来区分独处和意味着孤独的词。因此，作为一名独处研究人员，开展独处的研究其实相当困难，因为我们没有一种方式可以向参与者传达什么是独处，同时又不会把它和孤独混为一谈。当然，在社会中，当你称呼某人为“独行侠”（loner）时，这并不是一句赞美。完全正确，独行侠并不是指感到孤独的人，独行侠是指花时间独自度过的人。因此我们确实把它们放在同一个认知空间里。正因为我们倾向于这样做，并且从历史上看一直是这样，作为我们文化和传统的一部分，而且在世界各地，这种情况依然存在，
we don't have as much of an opportunity to consider solitude as a neutral thing, or even as a positive experience in our lives. When you think about loneliness as being distinct from solitude, how would you define it? If you were to come up with a definition that cleanly carves out loneliness from the concept of solitude, how would you cleave them apart, Netta? So if we think about loneliness, the definition of loneliness that psychologists use is the feeling that we are disconnected from others. It's the sense that we don't have the intimacy, the social connection, the love and caring in our lives that we desire or need. love and caring in our lives that we desire and need.
我们没有那么多机会把独处看作一件中立的事情，甚至看作我们生活中的一种积极体验。当你把孤独（loneliness）视为与独处（solitude）不同时，你会如何定义它？如果你要提出一个将孤独从独处概念中清晰剥离出来的定义，你会如何将它们分开，内达？因此，如果我们考虑孤独，心理学家使用的孤独的定义是我们与他人断开连接的感觉。这是这样一种感觉：我们没有我们所渴望或需要的亲密感、社会联系、爱与关怀。我们渴望和需要的爱与关怀。
So loneliness by its definition is a deficit in something that is important to us. And it's a feeling that says, there's something, you know, warning, there is something wrong. And it's a negative emotion for that reason. Solitude on the other hand, is kind of much more vanilla, really. It's really the state of being alone. So the state of being alone really just means about whether there are people around me or whether I'm interacting with other people.
因此，根据其定义，孤独是对对我们重要的事情的一种缺失。这是一种传达以下信息的感受：有事情，你知道的，发出警告，有什么不对劲。出于这个原因，它是一种消极情绪。另一方面，独处要“平淡”得多。它实际上只是独自一人的状态。因此，独自一人的状态实际上仅仅意味着周围是否有其他人，或者我是否在与其他其他人互动。
We can talk about sort of the specific nuances. But in all, it's really me being separated from other people. And it doesn't necessarily need to be a deficit. It can be neutral, it can feel lonely, but it can also be empowering and positive. There are certainly times when solitude can lead to loneliness. But because loneliness is a feeling and not a state,
我们可以讨论具体的细微差别。但总的来说，它确实是我与其他人分开。而且它不一定非得是一种缺失。它可以是中立的，可能会让人感到孤独，但它也可以是赋能的和积极的。当然，有时独处可能会导致孤独。但由于孤独是一种感觉而不是一种状态，
you can also be lonely in a crowd. Netta has an illustrative example from her own life. Many years ago, she moved from her home in upstate New York to Germany. She was excited about a work opportunity in Hamburg and found a place to stay that was in a fun part of town. So there was a lot in it that was really wonderful. But I think the thing that made it quite hard
你也可以在人群中感到孤独。内达有一个来自她自己生活的生动例子。多年前，她从纽约州北部的家搬到了德国。她对汉堡的一个工作机会感到兴奋，并在城里一个有趣的地方找到了一个住处。所以其中有很多内容真的很棒。但我认为让事情变得相当困难的是，
is that at least early on in that move, I went from once again having this close-knit community and this sense of familiarity. I really loved Rochester, and I really loved the people around me there, to being on my own and being a stranger in a new country and once again not speaking the language. So it felt very familiar and I moved from my house in Rochester and all my belongings
至少在那次搬迁的早期，我再次从拥有这个紧密联系的社区和这种熟悉感——我真的很喜欢罗切斯特，我真的很喜欢那里的周围人——转变为独自一人，成为一个新国家的陌生人，并且再次不会说这里的语言。所以感觉非常熟悉，我从罗切斯特的家里搬走，带着我所有的物品，
and it was just me and a couple of suitcases and I came in and there was very little in this apartment so it was really an empty space. Neta's mind filled with questions and self-doubt. Had she made the right move? As she sat in her apartment, she wondered, did it really make sense to leave behind a warm and loving community? When I was in Rochester, I'd go home to people who love me. And in Germany, I went home to this kind of, again, very barren apartment with nobody else in it. And it had this deep, but maybe sad for me, quiet.
只有我和几个手提箱，我走进去，这个公寓里几乎没有什么东西，所以它真的是一个空荡荡的空间。内达的脑海里充满了疑问和自我怀疑。她做对了搬家的决定吗？当她坐在公寓里时，她想，留下一个温暖而充满爱的社区真的有意义吗？当我在罗切斯特时，我回家面对的是爱我的人。而在德国，我回家面对的是这种再次非常荒凉、里面没有其他人的公寓。它有一种深沉的，但对我来说也许是悲伤的安静。
And it was a little unsettling because it sort of represented a little bit this big move I'd made and was it the right move and what did it mean, and what would my future hold? And it had all these big ideas attached to it. Neta was reminded that she was a stranger in a strange land when she did the most ordinary of things,
这有点让人不安，因为它在某种程度上代表了我所做出的这次大搬迁：这真的是正确的决定吗？这意味着什么？我的未来会怎样？所有这些宏大的想法都附着在它上面。当内达做最平常的事情时，她被提醒自己是一个异国他乡的陌生人，
like the time she bought a common household appliance. Moved from the U.S., and again again I had a house that was functioning and I moved to this apartment that had effectively nothing in it except for a couple of rooms and one of my goals was to get a washing machine because I thought you know if I can just have the devices that I need to sort of take care of myself How spectacular would that be? So I put myself to this task of getting a washing machine and I bought one online and I got it delivered to my doorstep. But it turned out when the washing machine came that it was in fact delivered to my doorstep. And so the nice delivery man came and he had this kind of cart to carry it and he dropped it off right in front of my apartment building.
比如她买一件普通家用电器的那个时候。从美国搬过去，同样地，我以前有一个运转正常的家，然后我搬到了这个实际上除了几个房间之外什么都没有的公寓，我的目标之一就是买一台洗衣机，因为我想，你知道的，如果我能拥有照顾自己所需的设备，
And so the only problem with that was that my apartment was three floors up and I I kind of gave him a look and he spoke no English and I spoke no German and I sort of pointed up the stairs and said, help. And he kind of looked at me and sort of shrugged his shoulders. And, you know, he said something around this is where I'm meant to deliver it, I imagine. And he left with his trolley with the washing machine on the street in front of my apartment building. And so that was a moment that sort of reflected the kind of maybe the isolation, the helplessness around sort of this big move in this strange country where people do things very differently. Unlike the US, the apartment building that I lived in didn't have an elevator. And so the big challenge was how do I, with not a lot of upper body strength, get a washing
那该有多棒啊！所以我着手去买一台洗衣机，我在网上买了一台，并让人把它送到我的家门口。但结果证明，当洗衣机送来时，它确实被送到了我的家门口。那个友好的送货员带着一个运送它的推车来了，把它直接放在了我公寓楼的前面。唯一的麻烦是，我的公寓在三楼，我看着他，他不会说英语，我也不会说德国话，我指了指楼梯并说：“帮帮我”。他看了看我，耸了耸肩膀。然后，你知道的，他说了些类似“这就是我注定要送到地方，我想”之类的话。然后他推着手推车走了，而洗衣机就留在我公寓楼前的街上。所以那一刻某种程度上反映了——面对这种在一个陌生国家的重大搬迁时，人们做事情的方式非常不同——那种孤立感和无助感。与美国不同，我住的公寓楼没有电梯。因此，最大的挑战是，在上肢力量不足的情况下，我该如何把一台洗衣机
machine up three flights of stairs. For some time I had no answer to that question. Netta eventually figured out how to get the washing machine up to her apartment. But perhaps because lots of people have had experiences like the one she had in Germany, she finds that many of us have come to fear solitude because we believe it will lead to loneliness. Netta and her colleagues find people will go to great lengths to avoid silently spending time alone with their thoughts. In one set of studies, the researchers had people choose between solitude and being bored. We ran a series of studies that was led by my collaborator, Tuy Vinh Nguyen. And in those studies, we asked people to sit alone with their thoughts, or they could engage in a task.
搬上三层楼梯。有一段时间，我对这个问题毫无答案。内达最终想出了如何把洗衣机弄到她的公寓里。但也许是因为很多人都有过她在德国时的那种经历，她发现我们许多人开始害怕独处，因为我们相信它会导致孤独。内达和她的同事发现，人们会竭尽全力避免独自默默地与自己的想法共处。在一组研究中，研究人员让人们在独处和感到无聊之间做出选择。我们进行了一系列研究，由我的合作者杜伊·温·阮（Tuy Vinh Nguyen）领导。在这些研究中，我们要求人们独自静坐并与自己的想法相处，或者他们可以参与一项任务。
And the task was to organize pencils. So we gave them about 1500 blue and red pencils. So we gave them about 1500 blue and red pencils that were all combined together in kind of one big box. We said, okay, your task now is to sort those pencils into the red pile and the blue pile. And they could either sit with their thoughts or they could sort pencils. We found that they could sort pencils, we found that they overwhelmingly selected to continue to sort pencils and sorted about 200 more each on average. So in other words, people prefer to do this excruciatingly boring task rather than sit by themselves alone with their thoughts. It seems so. So in some ways clearly there's a mystery here, Netta. People, you know People clearly hate being alone and they go to great lengths to distract themselves from feelings of being alone.
这项任务是整理铅笔。所以我们给了他们大约1500支蓝色和红色的铅笔。所以我们给了他们大约1500支蓝色和红色的铅笔，它们都混杂在一个大盒子。我们说，好吧，你现在的任务是将这些铅笔分类到红色的堆里和蓝色的堆里。他们要么可以与自己的想法共处，要么可以整理铅笔。我们发现，他们可以整理铅笔，我们发现他们压倒性地选择继续整理铅笔，平均每人多整理了大约200支。换句话说，人们宁愿做这种极其无聊的任务，也不愿独自一人与自己的想法共处。看起来确实如此。因此，从某些方面来看，内达，这里显然存在一个谜团。人们，你知道的，
At the same time, when aloneness, if you will, is forced on them, as it was during the pandemic, many people reported not just negative feelings, but positive feelings as well. It is telling that around the world, so many millions of people have chosen not to go back into offices to continue to work from home and often to work by themselves. Many companies have gone to great lengths to induce employees to come back in the office, but lots of people have said no thanks. I understand that you might have a theory about what might be going on here that is rooted in some research that you did that took place before you started studying solitude. This was research on the subject of relationships.
人们显然讨厌独处，并且他们会竭尽全力让自己从孤独的感觉中转移注意力。与此同时，当孤独，如果你愿意这么说的话，被强加给他们时——就像在大流行期间那样——许多人不仅报告了消极感受，也报告了积极感受。这说明了一个问题：在世界各地，数以百万计的人选择不回到办公室，而是继续在家工作，并且经常独自工作。许多公司付出了巨大努力来引诱员工回到办公室，但许多人说“谢谢，不用了”。我了解到，关于这里可能正在发生的事情，你可能有一个理论，它植根于你在开始研究独处之前所做的一些研究。这是关于人际关系主题的研究。
Tell me about that work, Netta, and how you think it has bearing on the experience of being alone. For many years, my interest was in what makes for positive interactions, how do we bring our best selves forward to interactions, and how do other people help us be our best selves? And I was really interested in that question. And you know, one of the things that was really powerful in that was
内达，跟我聊聊那项工作，以及你认为它对独自一人的体验有什么影响。多年来，我的兴趣在于是什么促成了积极的互动，我们如何将最好的自我带入互动中，以及其他人如何帮助我们成为最好的自己？我对那个问题真的很感兴趣。你知道的，其中真正有力的一点是，
that the best relationships, the best interactions are ones where we can bring our full selves forward, where people accept us, where we feel we can be heard, that we can express ourselves, where our behaviors and our actions are ones that we choose to do, they're ones we value and that interest us. So in a sense, me being fully myself with other people was sort of the pinnacle of social relationships. And other people could help me to do that or they could sort of stand in my way and be pressuring and demanding or judgmental instead of allowing me to fully express myself. So how did you apply this insight now in your new interest in the subject of solitude?
最好的关系、最好的互动是我们能够展现完整的自我、人们接纳我们、我们感到自己被倾听、我们能够表达自己、我们的行为和行动是我们选择去做的、是我们重视且感兴趣的事情。因此从某种意义上说，我和其他人在一起时完全做自己，可以说是社会关系的巅峰。其他人可以帮助我做到这一点，或者他们可能会挡我的路，变得具有强迫性、要求苛刻或爱评头论足，而不是允许我充分表达自己。那么，你现在是如何将这一洞察应用到你对独处主题的新兴趣中的呢？
Did you draw a connection between these two things? I think solitude is just a really big gap in our knowledge of what wellbeing looks like. Because for me, that question of what makes for a great relationship or a great interaction, that was really about how do we have a sense of wellbeing and fulfillment in our lives? Where does that come from? And the question of whether I can be my own
你在这两件事之间建立联系了吗？我认为独处只是我们在幸福感究竟是什么样子的知识上的一个巨大空白。因为对我来说，关于什么构成了一段伟大的关系或一次伟大的互动的那个问题，实际上是关于我们如何在生活中获得幸福感和满足感。那是从哪里来的？以及我是否能成为我自己的
really supportive friend became a really intriguing question of, do we really always need other people to be the ones who support and empower us, I guess, in a way to allow us to be authentic or be autonomous? Or actually, is that sort of a power that we have within us to do that for ourselves? I mean, I think what I'm hearing, Neda, is that as you talk about how we feel happy in our social relationships,
真正支持性的朋友这个问题，变成了一个非常引人入胜的问题：我们是否真的总是需要其他人来成为支持和赋予我们力量的人，我猜，在某种程度上允许我们做自己或保持自主？或者实际上，那是我们内在的一种力量，可以为我们自己做到这一点？我的意思是，内达，我听到的是，当你谈论我们在社会关系中如何感到快乐时，
we feel like we are most ourselves when we feel heard, when we feel understood, when we feel we're not being judged. In some ways, when we bring that same model to how we spend time with ourselves, if we treat ourselves with the same kind of concern that we treat close friends, you're saying that that's more likely then
当我们感到被倾听、当我们感到被理解、当我们觉得没有被评判时，我们会觉得自己最像自己。在某些方面，当我们把同样的模式带到我们如何与自己共处时，如果我们以对待亲密朋友的那种关怀来对待自己，你的意思是，这更有可能
to lead to us feeling happy with ourselves when we are alone? Yeah, absolutely. And we're starting to see this in research findings. So one of the findings that have come across is that when we are compassionate with ourselves, that really helps us to get a sense of peace and well-being and solitude.
导致我们在独处时对自我感到快乐？是的，绝对如此。我们开始在研究发现中看到这一点。因此，出现的发现之一是，当我们对自我抱有同情心时，这确实能帮助我们在独处中获得平和感和幸福感。
And so just like other people can be good friends to us, they can be supportive, understanding, empathic, forgiving, and kind. And then those are the kind of conversations and relationships where we feel like, wow, that person really gave me a sense of well-being. I'm really glad I had that conversation and I got a lot out of it. When we're kind to ourselves, accepting with ourselves and understanding,
因此，就像其他人可以成为我们的好朋友一样，他们可以是支持性的、理解的、共情的、宽容的和善良的。然后，这些就是那种让我们觉得“哇，那个人真的给了我一种幸福感，我很高兴我有过那次对话并且从中收获颇丰”的对话和关系。当我们对自已善良、接纳自我并给予理解时，
it builds a stronger relationship with ourselves that makes for really positive solitude time. We think, I do wanna spend more time with that person, that person being me, and I'm happy to go back into solitude and have another conversation with myself. And in contrast, you know, if solitude is a place where, you know, dark thoughts are constantly bubbling up,
它会建立起与自己更强大的关系，从而带来非常积极的独处时间。我们会想：我确实想花更多时间与那个人（那个特定的人就是我自己）相处，我很高兴回到独处状态，并与自己进行另一场对话。相比之下，你知道的，如果独处是一个
you're consumed with rumination, regret, self-blame, presumably that's not going to be a very happy state and it's not going to be a state you would be eager to go back into. Absolutely. And what researchers are finding is that when you look at everyday solitude that people experience, we call it kind of little s solitude, the solitude that we're all familiar with. When you look at everyday solitude, what people are seeing is that
黑暗的想法不断涌现、你被反刍、遗憾、自责所吞噬的地方，想必那不会是一种非常快乐的状态，也不会是你渴望再次进入的状态。绝对是这样。而研究人员发现的是，当你审视人们经历的日常独处时——我们称之为某种程度上的“小s独处”（little s solitude），也就是我们都熟悉的独处——当你审视日常独处时，人们看到的是，
especially for certain groups of people, everyday solitude isn't always a sort of positive contribution to their lives. So if you compare their moments in solitude to their moments where social interactions, solitude can sometimes come out as being more stressful and less positive than social interactions. But what researchers find is that a lot of that has to do with the kinds of thoughts that we have when we're in solitude. So when we tend to sort of ruminate and get lost in our thoughts in a destructive way, that can lead to solitude being quite difficult. And the sort of fascinating thing about solitude
特别是对于某些群体来说，日常独处并不总是对他们的生活做出积极的贡献。因此，如果你将他们在独处时的时刻与他们进行社会互动的时刻进行比较，独处有时会显得比社会互动更有压力、更不积极。但研究人员发现，这很大程度上与我们在独处时产生的想法有关。因此，当我们倾向于反刍并以一种破坏性的方式迷失在自己的想法中时，这可能会导致独处变得相当困难。而关于独处的奇妙之处在于，
is that it's kind of the same characteristics of solitude that make it wonderful, which also can make it really difficult, which is when we're alone, there's no one there to distract us. There aren't other people to tell us what we should be thinking about or to pull our attention away from ourselves. We don't have to kind of negotiate what we're doing. And so we create our own journey. We have a lot of space and time to do that. And we can really reflect on ourselves. And when we talk to people, we see some people love that
正是独处的那些特征让它变得美妙，但也可能让它变得非常困难，那就是当我们独处时，没有人会在那里分散我们的注意力。没有其他人告诉我们应该考虑什么，或者把我们的注意力从自己身上拉开。我们不必去协商我们在做什么。因此我们创造了自己的旅程。我们有大量的空间和时间来做到这一点。我们可以真正地反思自我。当我们与人们交谈时，我们看到有些人喜欢这样，
and some people really struggle with that emptiness and openness. Are there personality traits that predict that people will be happy when they are by themselves versus unhappy, Netta? We're still learning a lot about that, but what we're finding so far is that one of the kind of superpowers of positive solitude is a tendency to be really curious and interested, interested in ourselves, interested in the world around us, inquisitive, and bringing those aspects to our solitude time. We found in some research that people who have what we call an autonomous orientation, that is, they tend to take more of an interest in their emotions, they act
而有些人则真的很挣扎于那种空虚和开放。内达，有没有什么性格特征能够预测人们在独自一人时会感到快乐还是不快乐？我们仍在对此进行大量了解，但我们迄今为止发现的是，积极独处的“超能力”之一是倾向于真正充满好奇心和兴趣，对自我感兴趣、对外在世界感兴趣、好 inquisitive（爱探究），并将这些方面带入我们的独处时间。我们在一些研究中发现，具有我们所谓的自主导向（autonomous orientation）的人——也就是说，他们倾向于对自己的情绪产生更多兴趣，他们以
in a more what we call self congruent way. That is, when they act, it comes from their deep valuing of the actions that they're taking and their deep interest. So they kind of act in a way that's congruent with the self and they don't tend to follow sort of the kind of pressures and societal pressures as much, that those people find more value in solitude and seek it for the value that it has. One of the things that I think most people would assume is that the people most likely to want and seek solitude
一种我们称之为自我一致（self congruent）的方式行动。也就是说，当他们行动时，这来自于他们对所采取行动的深深珍视和深厚兴趣。因此他们的行动方式与自我相一致，并且他们往往不那么倾向于跟随那种压力和社会的压力，那些人能在独处中发现更多价值，并为了其本身的价值而去寻求独处。我认为大多数人都会做出的假设之一是，最有可能想要并寻求独处的人
are introverts, and the people least likely to want and seek solitude are introverts and the people least likely to want and seek solitude are going to be extroverts. Does the data bear out that intuition? You know it's really fascinating because I at this point I would say it's unclear. We have some studies that including studies that I've been involved in where we found no relationship at all with introversion. We do see some research. There's a study out of Taiwan conducted in 2020 where researchers were looking at undergraduate students and what they found is that those students who identified as having more
是内向者，而最不容易想要并寻求独处的人将是外向者，而最不容易想要并寻求独处的人将是外向者。数据是否印证了这种直觉？你知道的，这真的很迷人，因为在这一点上，我会说这并不明确。我们有一些研究，包括我曾参与过的一些研究，发现在内向性方面完全没有关系。我们确实看到了一些研究。2020年在台湾开展的一项研究中，研究人员观察了本科生，他们发现那些被识别为具有更多
introversion tended to also have more capacity for solitude. So they enjoyed it more, they were able to reflect more when they were in it. So we're finding different evidence, but fairly weak evidence on the whole, much more so than we might anticipate that introversion sort of drives the desire for solitude. We're also finding extroverts can enjoy solitude just as much. Neta and other researchers find that solitude can calm people down and reduce stress levels. One study examined the effects of solitude on creativity. What the researchers did was they put participants in a room and they asked them to write poetry. All the participants wrote a poem in silence.
内向特质的学生往往也具有更强的独处能力。所以他们更享受独处，当他们处于独处时能够进行更多的反思。因此我们找到了不同的证据，但总体而言证据相当微弱，远没有我们预期的那样——即内向性在某种程度上驱动了对独处的渴望。我们也发现外向者同样可以享受独处。内达和其他研究人员发现，独处可以让人平静下来并降低压力水平。一项研究检验了独处对创造力的影响。研究人员做的是，他们把参与者关在一个房间里，让他们写诗。所有参与者都在安静中写了一首诗。
And then they took some of their participants and randomly assigned them to write another poem once again in silence. And they took the rest of the participants and they assigned them to write their second poem with interruptions of noise. And what they did was they piped into the lab noise blasts that were 85 decibels, which is just kind of at the upper edge of what's okay for human hearing. And so some participants who were writing their poems with these noise blasts and what researchers found was, you know, when they compared the two conditions,
然后他们让一部分参与者随机去写另一首诗，同样是在安静的环境中。接着他们让其余的参与者在有噪音干扰的情况下写第二首诗。他们做的是将85分贝的噪音传送到实验室里，这刚好处于人类听觉正常承受范围的上限。因此，有些参与者在这些噪音干扰下写诗，研究人员发现，你知道的，当他们对比这两种情况时，
the participants who could write their poetry in quiet wrote more creative original poems than those who had disruptions by noise. And in some ways, I guess this makes sense to every office worker in the world who tells her boss, stop interrupting me, I can't get any work done if I have to keep answering emails from you. This makes sense to every office worker in the world who tells her boss, stop interrupting me. I can't get any work done if I have to keep answering emails from you.
那些能在安静环境中写诗的参与者，比那些受到噪音干扰的人写出了更有创造力、更原创的诗歌。从某种程度上说，我想这让世界上每一个对老板说“别打扰我，如果我得一直回复你的邮件，我就什么工作都干不完了”的办公室职员都感同身受。这让世界上每一个对老板说“别打扰我”的办公室职员都感同身受。如果我得一直回复你的邮件，我就什么工作都干不完了。
Absolutely. So when we're around other people, we can have a breadth of ideas exposed to us. So we think broadly, we get new ideas, we can bounce off of each other. And that has a benefit to certain forms of creativity. But what we see in solitude is that people's minds can wonder and we talked earlier about that being potentially difficult, but it's also a place where creativity happens. When our mind is allowed to wonder, we can dig deep into, you know, our ideas and learn more about them, develop them, and we can think more originally about the the kinds
绝对是的。所以当我们和别人在一起时，我们可以接触到广泛的想法。因此我们思维开阔，能获得新的想法，并且可以互相启发。这对某些形式的创造力是有好处的。但我们在孤独中看到的是，人们的思想可以天马行空，我们之前讨论过这可能比较困难，但这也是创造力发生的地方。当我们的思想被允许漫游时，我们可以深入挖掘我们的想法，更多地了解它们，发展它们，并且我们可以对我们想要做出的各种贡献进行更具原创性的思考。
of contributions that we want to make. We can create artistic works, musical works, and we hear a lot of stories of solitude being a wonderful space for those forms of creativity. Solitude can give people a chance to understand themselves, but it also seems to help people understand their place in the world. Neda remembers a time after she first graduated from high school when she spent days, like William Wordsworth, hiking in the British countryside. Those were the first real deep moments of solitude and exploring in solitude that I had. And it was a really powerful moment in my life because those days of hiking were days of exploring opportunities.
我们可以创作艺术作品、音乐作品，我们听到很多关于孤独是孕育这些形式创造力的绝佳空间的故事。孤独可以让人有机会了解自己，而且它似乎也能帮助人们理解自己在世界上的位置。内达记得她刚高中毕业后的一段经历，当时她像威廉·华兹华斯一样，在英国乡村徒步旅行了几天。那是我经历的最初真正深刻的孤独时刻，以及在孤独中探索的时刻。那是我生命中一个非常具有力量的时刻，因为那几天的徒步旅行是探索机遇的日子。
And those opportunities came in the form of paths that were open to me. They're these beautiful walkways and walking paths all across the UK that allow you to kind of explore and get a little bit lost. And there were days when it was just me and fields of green and hedges and sheep and nobody else around. That was the first time that I felt a peak experience, which is an experience described in psychology, that is a moment usually brief, where we feel this sense of sort of oneness with the world, and we feel a sense of joy and awe. And so there are these really powerful, positive moments.
而这些机遇以向我敞开的道路的形式出现。英国各地都有这些美丽的人行道和小径，让你能够去探索并稍微迷失一下方向。有几天，周围只有我和一片片的绿色田野、树篱和绵羊，没有其他人。那是我第一次感受到巅峰体验，这是心理学中描述的一种体验，通常是一个短暂的时刻，在这个时刻我们感受到与世界融为一体的感觉，并感受到一种喜悦和敬畏。所以这些确实是非常强大、积极的时刻。
And for me, those were moments that came from really being with nature, with the sheep, with the grass, with the hedges, and nobody else around. Solitude can offer us positive feelings of being autonomous, authentic, and competent. It can provide us a portal to some of the most intense and meaningful experiences of our lives. But being alone well is a skill, one that many of us have not yet fully developed. When we come back, how to get the most out of solitude? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant.
对我来说，那些时刻来自于真正与大自然、与绵羊、与青草、与树篱相伴，周围没有其他人。孤独可以带给我们自主、真实和能力的积极感受。它能为我们打开通往生活中一些最强烈、最有意义的体验的大门。但好好独处是一项技能，许多人尚未完全掌握这项技能。当我们回来时，将探讨如何充分利用孤独？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Counselors and confidants tell us how to improve our relationships with other people. Not many teach us to become better friends with ourselves. Neda Weinstein is a psychologist at the University of Reading in England. Along with Heather Hansen and Thuy Nguyen, she is co-author of the book, Solitude, the Science and Power of Being Alone. Neda, you say that the first step to becoming better friends with ourselves is to understand the stories we tell ourselves about what it means to be alone. In 2020, researchers published an interesting study where they provided people different
顾问和知己告诉我们如何改善与其他人的关系。没有多少人教我们如何成为自己的好朋友。内达·韦恩斯坦是英国雷丁大学的心理学家。她与海瑟·汉森和崔阮合著了《孤独：独处的科学与力量》一书。内达，你说成为自己好朋友的第一步，是去理解我们对自己所讲述的关于独处意味着什么的那些故事。2020年，研究人员发表了一项有趣的研究，他们向人们提供了对独处的不同
interpretations of being alone. Tell me what they did and what they found. Researchers conducted a really fascinating experiment where they asked people to be alone, but before they did that, they put them in a number of conditions. And one of those conditions was called the loneliness debiasing condition. And in that condition, researchers just kind of highlighted, you know, it's okay and normal to feel lonely. We all feel lonely sometimes. There's nothing kind of scary or unnatural about it. And what researchers found is when they then asked participants to spend 10 minutes alone, on the whole, participants didn't particularly like this activity. They had a drop in their
解读。告诉我他们做了什么，以及他们发现了什么。研究人员做了一个非常迷人的实验，他们要求人们独处，但在做这件事之前，他们让受试者处于几种不同的情境中。其中一种情境被称为“消除孤独偏见”的情境。在这种情境下，研究人员只是强调，感到孤独是正常且可以接受的。我们有时都会感到孤独。这并没有什么可怕或不自然的。研究人员发现，当他们随后要求参与者独处10分钟时，总体而言，参与者并不是特别喜欢这项活动。他们的情绪出现了下滑
positive affect. But participants who were in the loneliness,-debiasing condition didn't show this drop the way the participants in the other conditions did. So it sort of protected them from solitude being difficult for them during that period. Hmm. I mean, in some ways what it suggests is that our expectations and perhaps even our socially constructed expectations about solitude shape whether we get something out of it or we are hurt by it. Absolutely. So it could be the loneliness has a self-fulfilling prophecy where we
积极的情绪。但是处于消除孤独偏见情境中的参与者并没有像其他情境中的参与者那样表现出这种情绪的下降。所以这在那个时间段内保护了他们，使他们不觉得孤独是件痛苦的事。嗯。从某种程度上说，这表明我们的期望，甚至可能包括我们对孤独的社会构建的期望，决定了我们是能从中获得收获，还是会受到它的伤害。绝对是的。所以这可能是因为孤独有一种自我实现预言的作用，即我们
expect that if we're going to be alone, there's something wrong with us. We're going to be lonely. It means that we're failures. And it's those kinds of expectations and ideas we have about solitude, the kind of solitude stigma that sets us up for having a difficult time when we then are alone. Many of us find that when we spend time with ourselves, Netta, we get caught in unpleasant and unproductive patterns of thinking.
期望如果我们要独处，就说明我们身上有什么不对劲。我们会感到孤独。这意味着我们是失败者。正是这种关于孤独的期望和想法，这种孤独的污名，让我们在之后独处时经历艰难时期。内达，我们许多人发现，当我们花时间与自己相处时，我们会陷入令人不快且没有成效的思维模式中。
Of course, psychologists call this rumination. What can we do when we're alone and we realize that we're slipping into one of these mental ruts? Because presumably it's one of the reasons many of us find solitude or being alone to be in aversive state. Yes, absolutely. So even those of us who are solitude lovers might have times and moments where we actually feel that solitude is quite difficult. Maybe we've made a terrible mistake at work and we're ruminating and regretting it, or
当然，心理学家称之为反刍思维。当我们独自一人并意识到自己正陷入这种思维死胡同之一时，我们可以做些什么？因为这大概就是为什么我们许多人觉得孤独或独处是一种厌恶状态的原因之一。是的，完全如此。所以即使是我们这些热爱孤独的人，也可能会有那么一些时刻，真正觉得孤独相当困难。也许我们在工作中犯了个可怕的错误，我们正在反刍并后悔，或者
maybe we have something else difficult going on and we're tending to really focus in on that and we seem to be unable to get out of those feelings. The first step to really reshaping our relationship with ourselves the way that we're thinking and then our solitude time is to have awareness of it and take an interest in it. Research on emotion regulation and what we're finding out of the solitude research both sort of point to being able to step back and be curious about our emotions, be interested in our feelings and what's going on for us, and kind hear this and think, gosh, well, that doesn't sound like something I can do. But it's something that the more we practice, the better we can get at. So we start small and start to practice that way of kind of thinking about ourselves.
也许我们身上发生了其他棘手的事情，而我们往往会真正专注于此，并且似乎无法摆脱那些情绪。真正重塑我们与自己关系、重塑我们思维方式以及随后重塑我们独处时间的第一步，是对其有所觉察并产生兴趣。关于情绪调节的研究以及我们从孤独研究中发现的成果，都指向一点，即能够退一步，对我们的情绪保持好奇，对我们的感觉以及正在我们身上发生的事情感兴趣，并且听到这些时会想，天哪，这听起来不像是顺便能做到的事。但这是我们练习得越多，就能做得越好的事情。所以我们从小事做起，开始练习那种思考自己的方式。
And over time, we sort of build that as a strength. Netta says that just as we plan outings with friends, We can think about solitude crafting as a way of intentionally approaching our solitude. And we've been doing a series of studies where we try to facilitate solitude crafting, but it's something that we can all do at home. What do I wanna get out of my solitude time? We sometimes find that solitude is more positive when people have a plan for it. Some people even have traditions that they've talked about where they might light candles
随着时间的推移，我们将其培养成一种优势。内达说，就像我们计划与朋友出游一样，我们可以将“孤独塑造”视为一种刻意接近孤独的方式。我们一直在做一系列研究，试图促进孤独的塑造，但这其实是我们所有人都能在家中做到的事情。我想从我的独处时间中得到什么？我们有时发现，当人们对孤独有所规划时，孤独会更积极。有些人甚至有他们谈论过的传统，比如他们可能会点燃蜡烛
or they might play certain music and they create a setup for themselves. The means at that time is then as rewarding and self-fulfilling as it can be. We've talked a bit about the idea of being out in nature as being one of the engines of solitude. Can you explain what it is that being alone with ourselves outdoors, why that's so special? Sure, you know nature and solitude sort of go hand in hand in a beautiful way. being alone with ourselves outdoors, why that's so special? Sure. Nature and salt sort of go hand in hand in a beautiful way.
或者他们可能会播放特定的音乐，并为自己营造一个氛围。这意味着那个时刻将尽可能具有回报性和自我实现意义。我们之前讨论过置身于大自然是孤独的动力之一这一观点。你能解释一下，为什么独自一人在户外与自己相处是如此特别吗？当然，你知道大自然和孤独以一种美妙的方式齐头并进。为什么独自一人在户外与自己相处是如此特别？当然。大自然和独处以一种美妙的方式齐头并进。
They're kind of like strawberries and whipped cream. They just really work together. When we're alone in nature, there are a couple of benefits. The first one is nature connection, that sense of me being connected to the world around me and being connected to the birds and the animals and the plants around me, that that in itself can be fulfilling in much the same way that social connection is. When we're in nature, we also have what researchers call soft fascination, which is
它们有点像草莓配鲜奶油。它们真的完美契合。当我们独自在大自然中时，有几个好处。第一个是与自然的连接，那种我与周围世界相连、与周围的鸟类、动物和植物相连的感觉，这本身就可以带来满足感，其方式与社会连接非常相似。当我们在大自然中时，我们还会体验到研究人员所说的“柔和吸引力”，也就是
our attention is receiving what's happening around us in a mindful way. We think about what is currently happening in terms of the leaves rustling, the birds chirping and we're also thinking very much about our actions. What our next step is going to be if we're going on a hike, for example, how we'll sort of cross that boulder. So we tend to be very focused in the space around us and the present moment. And nature helps us really focus to the present moment.
我们的注意力正在以正念的方式接收周围发生的事情。我们思考当下正在发生的事情，比如树叶的沙沙声、鸟儿的鸣叫，同时我们也非常关注自己的行动。如果我们去徒步旅行，比如我们将要采取的下一步是什么，我们将如何跨过那块巨石。因此，我们往往非常专注于我们周围的空间和当下。大自然帮助我们真正专注于当下。
And it also really satisfies our senses in a wonderful way. I'm wondering whether the search for solitude can negatively affect our relationships with other people. At some level, Netta, you know, if you're saying you want to be by yourself, doesn't that mean that you're saying you don't want to be with other people? Have you had experiences like this where you're seeking solitude but other people interpret what you're saying as you don't want to be with them? Yes, absolutely. So I think, you know,
它也以美妙的方式满足了我们的感官。我在想，对孤独的追求是否会负面影响我们与其他人的关系。在某种程度上，内达，你知道的，如果你说你想独自一人，这难道不意味着你是在说你不想和别人在一起吗？你是否有过这样的经历：你在寻求孤独，但其他人把你的话解读为你不想和他们在一起？是的，绝对有。所以我想，你知道，
because we see solitude in a negative light, and many other people around us will tend to see solitude in a negative light, it's hard for people to really think about any individual kind of seeking solitude because of the value in solitude. And so it's very easy for people to interpret needing solitude as wanting to get away from the other person. And often when we talk about solitude as wanting to get away from the other person. And often when we talk about solitude, we talk about it as the thing you do when you're not interacting with other people. So we think, well, we could be having a social interaction
因为我们以消极的眼光看待孤独，而且我们周围的许多人往往也以消极的眼光看待孤独，所以人们很难真正理解任何个人出于孤独的价值而寻求孤独。因此，人们很容易将需要孤独解读为想要离开对方。通常当我们把孤独谈作想要离开对方时，我们往往把它当作你在不与其他人互动时做的事情。所以我们认为，要么我们可以进行社交互动
or we can choose to be alone. And if we're choosing to be alone, it means we don't want to be with other people. And so, you know, it's very easy for people to assume that if you want to step away, if you want to have a bit of your alone time, that it's really a reflection of how you feel about them in the moment, that it means you don't want to be with them. And we see the people around us interpret that as meaning, well, you don't want to be with me.
或者我们可以选择独处。如果我们选择独处，就意味着我们不想和别人在一起。所以，你知道，人们很容易认为，如果你想离开，如果你想拥有一点独处时间，这实际上反映了你当下对他们的感觉，这意味着你不想和他们在一起。我们看到周围的人将此解读为意味着，好吧，你不想和我在一起。
So what do you do in a situation like that? How do you communicate that in some ways it's, if you will, not about you, it's about me? So, you know, I think the important thing is for us researchers and, you know, for people is to de-stigmatize solitude in a way. So if you wanna be alone and you're worried about hurting
那么在那种情况下你该怎么办？你如何传达在某种程度上，这“不是针对你，而是关于我”？所以，你知道，我认为重要的是，对我们研究人员以及对人们来说，要在某种程度上消除对孤独的 stigmatize（污名化）。所以如果你想独处，又担心伤害
somebody's feelings, one way to frame it is to say, I really haven't had a lot of great me time lately and that's something that I would really look forward to. And so conveying what the value of solitude is for you is part of making other people aware that, you know, solitude isn't about not wanting to be with others, but it's actually about how important it is for you to have that alone time. And I also like to say that when we talk to people about needing our solitude time, that it's important to highlight to them that I'm really looking forward later on to continuing this conversation with you, or I'm really looking forward to going out to coffee with you.
别人的感情，一种表达方式是说：“我最近真的没有太多属于自己的好时光，这是我非常期待的事情。”因此，传达孤独对你的价值，是让其他人意识到“孤独不是不想和别人在一起，而是拥有这段独处时间对你来说多么重要”的一部分。我也喜欢说，当我们与人们谈论需要独处时间时，向他们强调“我真的很期待稍后继续我们之间的对话”或是“我真的很期待和你一起去喝咖啡”，这一点很重要。
Let's find a different day to do it. Netta has also learned it's important to help others who crave solitude to not feel like there is something wrong with them. One of those other people was her own 10 year old daughter. She is creative and imaginative and she really loves her solitude time. And I've kind of always had a sense of this, also because she's very vocal about it. So she will say, I need my solitude time, and then she will go seek it. And so it's a little difficult to ignore that need that she has.
让我们改天再做这件事。内达还了解到，帮助那些渴望孤独的人不觉得自己有什么不对劲，这一点很重要。其中另一个人就是她10岁的女儿。她很有创造力和想象力，她非常喜欢自己的独处时间。我一直对这一点有所感悟，也因为她对此直言不讳。所以她会说，我需要我的独处时间，然后她就会去寻找它。因此，忽视她有的这种需求有点困难。
But when I was writing this book, we had just moved to a new house in a new neighborhood. And what I saw was the neighborhood kids came to visit and they would come. And when they came to the door, she would run to the door and she would politely decline that she didn't want to go out with them. She wanted to be in her new room, in her new space, doing her crafting and being creative. And you know, I was a little bit worried as a parent. I thought, gosh, well, I'd love Maya to have friends in the neighborhood. Will they stop coming around? What does this mean? Is there something wrong with her? And I was just chatting with my co-author, Heather Hansen, about the book at the time. And
但当我写这本书的时候，我们刚搬到一个新社区的新房子里。我看到社区里的孩子们来拜访，他们会来。当他们来到门口时，她会跑到门口，礼貌地拒绝和他们一起出去。她想待在自己的新房间里，在她的新空间里，做她的手工艺品，发挥创造力。你知道，作为一个家长，我有点担心。我想，天哪，我希望玛雅能在社区里交到朋友。他们还会来吗？这意味着什么？她有什么不对劲吗？当时我正和我的合著者海瑟·汉森聊关于这本书的事，然后
I kind of mentioned this to her because a child had come to the door and she said, you know, you're writing a book about how solitude can actually be a positive experience. And yet you're quite worried about your daughter here. And I realized that my gut reaction was to worry me that there's something wrong with my daughter because she wants to be alone. And so that was a real, for me, a big kind of eye-opening moment. And I thought as a parent,
我跟她提了这件事，因为有个孩子来敲门，她说：“你知道的，你正在写一本关于孤独如何实际上是一种积极体验的书。然而你却在这里为你的女儿感到相当担心。”我意识到我本能的反应是担心我女儿有什么不对劲，因为她想独处。所以对我来说，那是一个非常大的、令人大开眼界的时刻。我想作为一个家长，
maybe my job is to help support her in that rather than worry that there's something wrong with her for wanting to be in solitude. I understand that you recently celebrated a birthday. Tell me how you chose to spend this special day, Neda. So I decided to craft my own solitude and I thought, what is the ideal birthday for me? And I decided to spend my birthday in solitude having a long walk and just being with my thoughts.
也许我的工作是支持她，而不是因为她想独处就担心她有什么不对劲。我听说你最近庆祝了一个生日。内达，告诉我你是如何选择度过这个特殊的日子的。所以我决定打造属于我自己的孤独时光，我想，对理想中的我来说什么样的生日才是完美的？我决定在孤独中度过我的生日，进行长途散步，只和自己的思想在一起。
And so I put myself on a mission to go on a long walk and I went on a long walk by the beach. And I had the sea around me and the waves making sounds. I had a cup of coffee in my hand and coffee is kind of my, that's my great reward. So my sense of taste was quite happy and you know I just gave myself the opportunity to think not about research questions or not about what I have to do for work or for home, but just about whatever came to my mind. That was my ideal, ideal birthday, birthday present to myself. Neda Weinstein is a psychologist at the University of Reading in England. Along with Heather Hansen and Thuy Nguyen, she's co-author of the book
所以我给自己设定了一个任务去进行长途漫步，我去海滩边散步。周围是大海，海浪发出声响。我手里拿着一杯咖啡，咖啡算是我的一种，那是我的巨大奖励。所以我的味觉相当满足，你知道，我只是给了自己一个思考的机会，不去想研究问题，也不去想工作或家里必须做的事情，只去想任何浮现我脑海的事情。那是我的理想，我给自己的理想生日礼物。内达·韦恩斯坦是英国雷丁大学的心理学家。她与海瑟·汉森和崔阮合著了这本书
Solitude, the Science and Power of Being Alone. Neda, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristin Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Tom Waring. Tom works in creative partnerships at Patreon.
《孤独：独处的科学与力量》。内达，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。本节目由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·伯恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是汤姆·沃林。汤姆在Patreon负责创意合作伙伴关系。
A few weeks ago, we expanded our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus, to make it available for Android users and others on Patreon. Tom was our reliable guide in that process, walking us through every aspect of the expansion. He answered every question we had with speed and good humor. Thank you, Tom. If you'd like to try Hidden Brain Plus on Patreon,
几周前，我们扩展了我们的播客订阅服务《隐藏的大脑Plus》，使其向安卓用户以及Patreon上的其他人开放。汤姆是我们这一过程中的可靠向导，引导我们完成了扩展的各个方面。他以极高的效率和幽默感回答了我们提出的每一个问题。谢谢你，汤姆。如果你想在Patreon上体验《隐藏的大脑Plus》，
you can find it by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. That site again is support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're a user of Apple devices, you can always find Hidden Brain in Apple podcasts, That site again is support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're a user of Apple devices, you can always find Hidden Brain and Apple podcasts, or by going to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Your subscription helps us to bring you episodes like today's conversation with Neda Weinstein, and we truly appreciate your support. If today's episode inspired you to do your own solitude
你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 找到它。网址再次是 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你是苹果设备的用户，你总可以在苹果播客中找到《隐藏的大脑》，网址再次是 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你是苹果设备的用户，你总可以在苹果播客中找到《隐藏的大脑》，或者通过访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。你的订阅帮助我们为你带来像今天与内达·韦恩斯坦的对话这样的单集节目，我们由衷感谢你的支持。如果今天的单集节目启发你进行自己的独处
crafting, please send us a note and let us know how it went. You can reach us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. If you know someone else who might appreciate hearing about the benefits of solitude, please share this episode with them. Your recommendations are one of the best ways for us to connect new listeners with the ideas that we explore on the show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塑造，请给我们发便条，让我们知道进展如何。你可以通过 ideas@hiddenbrain.org 联系我们。如果你认识其他人可能会欣赏了解孤独带来的好处，请与他们分享这期节目。你的推荐是我们将新听众与我们在节目中探讨的想法联系起来的最佳途径之一。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。